running your youtube business can feel
overwhelming when it comes to making the
videos
and marketing the videos then getting in
your dms doing your social media as well
as
real life things like maybe picking up
what your two-year-old left for you or
having to go grocery shopping or dealing
with your in-laws drama
there are so many distractions when it
comes to being a business owner and in
today's episode
we're bringing you one of our business
mentors chalene johnson to talk with you
about five ways to kill distractions man
i need this
and to get more done in less time my
name is heather torres and you are
listening to the think marketing podcast
where we deliver a brand new episode
every single tuesday so if you're new to
the podcast
consider subscribing wherever you're
consuming this content on and
today's episode is brought to you by mia
bonus.com
after this episode i'll tell you how you
can score a two-hour
group mastermind with myself and sean
cannell when you enroll in the marketing
impact academy the doors are open and
i'll tell you more about it
after this episode well let's jump in
with sean cannell and chalene johnson
for our featured
conversation
as we head into a new year one of the
biggest enemies for us as content
creators and entrepreneurs is really not
a lack of information
it's a lack of implementation however
there's a
massive enemy that holds us back
from actually executing on what we need
to do to build our brands our youtube
channels
and our businesses and today i'm joined
by chalene johnson number one new york
times best-selling
author a fitness celebrity as well as
social media and marketing expert who's
built
multiple businesses and built and sold
multiple seven-figure businesses
and has been a major mentor in my life
not just to do the right steps in
business but to get my mind right to get
my time right
and i'm excited to be joined by chalene
johnson shaleen welcome
hey so good to be here what's going on
super great to see you
and one of the things you're so
passionate about
is this idea of killing distraction and
getting
focused what are we facing today as
content creators as entrepreneurs as
people that are trying to build our
businesses with social media when it
comes to
how important this issue is well i find
that a lot of people
who end up becoming entrepreneurs or end
up becoming content creators
tend to have a difficult time
thriving in a very structured
nine-to-five work for someone else kind
of environment which is
why we kind of lean towards doing our
own thing we
um we have a lot of different interests
we're good at figuring things out
we're we see little trends we see
details other people don't see
and frankly most of us are very easily
distracted it's the one thing i've
learned in the last 25 years of working
with people who either want to start a
business or want to scale a business is
that
we have this one thing in common most of
us like the number one
nemesis isn't that we don't have any
good ideas it's like there's so many
ideas bouncing around in our head and so
many different opportunities and so many
different things that we can do
that i think our number one enemy is
distraction
that's so powerful and thick marketing
podcasts you know think about this if
this is you
um are you guilty of wanting to write
three different ebooks start five
different youtube channels you're
tempted to
keep your instagram updated your
facebook updated now get on clubhouse
and listen to conversations while you
need to write that new email sequence
and then you also want to brainstorm for
other businesses
and you feel like you should also be on
tick tock right now and reels and
snapchat
because there's so much opportunity and
you're feeling guilty because you're not
keeping your pinterest
updated i really feel like that's kind
of the modern challenge
of us especially in the social media
space there's so much opportunity
but it's like opportunity overwhelm and
chalene there's a book called hook point
that revealed that over 60 billion
messages
are displayed on digital platforms every
day now that we are being hit by
5 000 to 10 000 marketing messages so if
it's not only our own calendar
our our attention is being pulled to
social media platforms
to the queen's gambit to hbo max to
watch
the flight attendant it like there's so
many different things
and therefore we end up reaching the end
of our day maybe not having accomplished
very many things that actually matter
for moving our business forward so i'm
excited about these five tips
but we are living literally in probably
one of the most difficult ages where
distraction
is 100x yeah it's so true
for me personally when i have i've
struggled with this kind of like all my
life
and i noticed my dad did too so i just
thought it was normal like this is just
how our brains operate um i was
fortunate enough to have a brain scan
and figured out that i have a pretty
severe case of attention
deficit disorder with some hyperactivity
and inattentiveness
which didn't surprise me it was just
like confirmation like oh
well i can't use that as an excuse but
this is more
than ever a reason for me to know that
i'm in charge
of my focus that this literally is
something that i
can be pulled in any different direction
so i've had to create
coping technique coping techniques and i
found that a lot of people they're like
i think i have add
should i go get tested i'm like you know
should you go test
i don't know but i do know this if you
think you have it you probably do and
even if you don't if you're easily
distracted which most of us are
you have got to put these systems in
place we have to teach these things to
our children
but if you're someone who's easily
distracted if you don't do these things
you start to beat yourself up you start
to do the whole comparing yourself to
other people
you have expectations for yourself each
day which you're not going to meet
because you're allowing distractions to
derail your day so i want to share with
your audience five like
really solid tips that have comple
that's it's what's
the only reason why i've been able to
have as much success
as i have with the kind of brain that i
have
is by learning to manage my brain like
celebrating it but also learning to
manage it
well i love it well hit us with number
one okay number one
i'm glad you mentioned clubhouse because
this is what helped me get off of
get off of clubhouse this week or last
week i should say and it's
repeating this question to myself
throughout the day and it is this
is this the best use of my time and
talent
right now in this moment and if the
answer
is no then i have to stop doing it if
the answer is
um i'm not sure but who else is going to
do it well then you've got to hire
someone else to do it
and ultimately if the answer is no this
isn't then you just literally have to
stop doing it
even if other people have you convinced
it's what you are supposed to do
we've got we've got to block out what
everyone else is doing and just know
is this the best use of my time and
talent for me right now i do this by
um triggering myself whenever i start to
we all have this like
the sense or this feeling that kind of
starts to bubble up when we're like
guy what am i doing i'm spinning my
wheels today what am i supposed to be
working on whenever i have that thought
i remind myself okay ask yourself that
question
it's a brilliant question and i'm guilty
of
being stuck in a room on clubhouse even
on stage
and for those that are maybe new to it
it's kind of a new app
it's invite only right now and of course
when something's budging it becomes a
shiny object
and shiny object syndrome can get you
stuck and off task really quick is this
the best use
of my time and talents right now and you
have to know how to evaluate that
question right so for some people
clubhouse is perhaps the best use of
their time and talent but for me it is
absolutely one thousand percent in this
moment the stage of which clubhouse has
developed to it is one thousand percent
the wrong use of my time and talent
i can't make an impact there the way i
can make an impact that i need to make
like doing a podcast like this is far
a far better use of my time and talent
so you have to evaluate it by knowing
like what's my objective
what is it i'm trying to accomplish this
year what stage am i
at in my business because if you just
start jumping around to everybody else's
stage and steps
you do everything out of order and your
house of cards crumbles you have to do
the right things in the right order
man powerful hit us with number two
number two is you need physical
reminders to keep
you on course so we wake up every day
and
a lot of entrepreneurs we we don't have
the same structure that we had in school
or the same structure that
we might have working in corporate
america where it's like okay the
meeting's at 10 and then
we have a zoom call and then i've got to
turn in my reports by this time
and that structure really works
beautifully if we're easily distracted
that's
why schools are you know set up on like
a 45-minute
bell system but once we're entrepreneurs
now we're at the mercy of our own
distractions so you need a physical
reminder of what you're supposed to be
doing
at that particular hour of the day a
physical reminder can be posted like
post-it notes are great um i use my day
planner i just keep it with me
and whenever i glance at it i carry it
in every single room like if i don't
have my planner with me
i get that same kind of overwhelm
whelming sense of drowning that most
people get when they don't have their
phone with them that's how i feel
when i don't have my planner with me so
it's for most of us who are easily
distracted it needs to be something
visual so a post-it note
a planner a pad of paper
something that's a reminder for you to
check in and say like what am i supposed
to be
doing right now so powerful and
i know for me i use google calendars
um and with like an apple watch and
you know we were just talking about how
phones can actually they can take you
down a road but the nice thing about a
watch is that it doesn't there's not a
lot you can do on it
and i get a 30 minute notification with
my day planned out that's like this is
the thing you need to prepare for and
the thing you need to do next
and i've learned that if what gets
scheduled gets done but if i just leave
my day as an open block
i can get into trouble quick and get off
task by not using my time in the best
way
i'm glad you mentioned that leads me to
point number three which is for those of
us who are very creative
we need a very set schedule but our
schedule is
different than most people's schedule
like so for example
i have about a five minute video that is
on my agenda to film today and
uh you know one of my other team members
assigned this to me and they they put on
my calendar and gave me a 15 minute
block of time
to record this five minute video which
probably to them they're like oh i gave
her three times the amount of time she
needs to film this
but i know myself personally in order to
get in that zone because i'm easily
distracted
i need to play i need to do certain
things to get myself in the right vibe
and to feel creative
and to really kill it so i need about an
hour thinking about that video before i
film that video and that might seem
excessive but if i don't do that i won't
be able to kill the video
i won't do a great job i won't enjoy the
process
and i'll get down on myself because i
didn't do it fast enough or i didn't
even do it that day because
15 minutes wasn't enough time so it's
using a schedule
here's the tip it's using a schedule
that allows for
the time you need to get in the zone
and enough time to be creative you know
that that's
most people who don't create content
don't understand
that we all have our own process for
getting in that zone
such a brilliant tip especially we um
recommend and talk about all the time
when people are shooting their youtube
videos to batch produce content i know
you do the same you'll batch produce
course content
batch produce social media content so
you have all that focused intensity
shooting a bunch of videos at once and
oftentimes and i'm guilty of it to this
day i
underestimate the time it'll take to
potentially
ramp up to get in the zone the time like
i get overconfident i'm like i'm gonna
shoot eight videos
in two hours and the next thing you know
it's it's going into the evening
and i think that's also maybe just being
more wise a little more gracious of
course we want to be effective
and we don't want to over schedule but i
noticed that we tend to
under schedule the amount of block time
necessary for creating content
yeah and and you we have to communicate
that to our team
if you have a team you have to
communicate that to them so that they
understand because we feel guilty about
it like guy you know i'm
i should be able to bust this out they
must think i'm a real slacker if i can't
film a five minute video in 15 minutes
but
um it's more than that it's a process
and getting into that zone
is is your is your secret sauce
no one else can do that no one else can
create content
that you're the star of nobody and
there's a reason why so
you've got to give yourself the
parameters and the grace
and the time to be able to do that and
know that
um it's worth it i'm excited for tip
number four
um what did jomo mean
jomo is the joy of missing out and um
you know i think we all know what fomo
is we you know had that fear of missing
out which
if to bring it back to any new social
media app right like so when
everyone started going crazy over tick
tock i'm like i gotta get everybody's
talking about tic tac i gotta get on
tick tock
everyone starts talking about clubhouse
i gotta get on clubhouse you know you
you have these
things you feel like if i'm not doing it
everyone else in my industry is gonna be
doing it and i'm gonna be left behind
but i've learned the only thing
that i can control is me
and by managing my focus
and doing less things then i have time
to do things i know i need to do
so while there are things i want to do i
shouldn't even touch those things until
i've completed the things
i know i need to do and we often
especially as creatives we love to go
do things that we we know we don't
really need to do but it feels like
we're doing something
and so therefore we feel uh productive
or creative
but we also have to be aware that it's
not what must be done
so you have to stop yourself and say
okay what things am i doing
right now daily and weekly that if i
remove them i would have more time to do
the things i actually need to do
so that might be mindlessly scrolling on
social media as much
as i want to look at everybody's social
media
i don't i i only respond to my dms and
and i post my content um and so i have
put on my do not do list you literally
this is my fourth tip is you need a do
not do list
and it can change all the time but right
now on my do not do list is
do not go on clubhouse i might go on it
a month from now but right now it's on
my do not do list
also on my do not do list is don't
just scroll through people's stories on
instagram it's on my do not do list
because i have so much i need to
accomplish this month
you know we're coming up on uh opening
up enrollment for marketing impact
academy
we've got a bunch of challenges that
we're doing and i've got to pour into my
students before i just pour into my own
mindless activities
so in writing i've created a do not do
lists and
then like you see how i've bragged a
couple of times about the fact that i'm
not on clubhouse i've done that just
because i'm trying to amp up my own
like i'm reinforcing my own joy of
missing out
that's such a powerful tip and i think
there's something about
you know the power
and the discipline it takes to not
do things and the joy of missing out and
it reminds me in 2020
obviously the world came to a screeching
halt especially in with a lockdown in
march 2020.
i had found myself in a routine
especially with
my prominence in youtube specifically
and my network of friendships
at like every event and it built up over
the years
years over years i was going to vid
summit and i'd be at vidcon
and i'd be a video marketing world and
i'd be a social media marketing world
and they were all amazing
and like they're all in the sense of all
friends i also like you want to like you
know with michael stelzner and daryl
you like want to have the relationships
but when forced
when things were forced off of my
calendar it was
remarkable how much more effective think
media became
our business actually grew at an
exceptional level
not just because of maybe increased
social media consumption youtube
viewership that's one piece
it grew because i was actually working
on priorities because i was forced to
this is so powerful chalene because we
are not necessary no one is actually
a pandemic's not finding its way into
our house homes hopefully
hanging over our shoulders and saying
don't go on clubhouse right now
don't get stuck on an instagram feed do
you even need to be on that social media
platform right now
why are you worried about you know one
of my uh
life-changing programs i was a part of
was the marketing impact academy i
learned about lean magnets learned about
uh freemiums and sometimes when we were
helping people that have joined and been
a part of that
they've they've talked about here's the
three freemiums i want to create
it's like dude you don't need to create
three you need to create one before you
create a second one
right there's four course ideas i have
here's three youtube
we don't necessarily have somebody or an
event or circumstance that clears our
calendar
but my god when you're forced into focus
the level of productivity it's not just
like 10x it can be like 100x a thousand
x
when we actually see all these places
our time is leaking yeah
i mean as you're a perfect example um i
when when we go to events which is what
you mentioned you definitely feel like
well you can convince yourself that it's
the best use of your time you can
convince yourself like
no this is great i'm networking with the
right people and getting my name out
there
which is true i need to do that i need
to do that but is there something i need
to do
that moves that really moves the needle
in a more profound way and the answer to
that
is is yes and for you that was
like your email list this year friggin
blew
up blew up and as i always like to say
like i i had a conversation recently
with a friend of mine who was
um well to be honest she was complaining
about the fact that women
aren't making as much money in in this
space
as as men are and she's like i'm sick of
hearing about these guys having this
seven-figure launch and that
seven-figure launch like
why is it women can't make that kind of
money and i said well there are women
that
make that kind of money and she said
well i don't i don't
know what what i'm doing wrong i said
well let's talk about how much time you
devote to building your email list
because those are your deepest most
hardcore
serious members of your community those
are the people who aren't just like on
your stories
or watching your content weekly these
are the people like raising their hand
and saying like i want to know all the
things
and they're opening up your emails and
so your
income is so incredibly related
not to your gender per se but to your
the size of your email list i just
i i know that to be true because i've
seen it from
countless people who are really
successful and it's not about like
working harder or who's working
longer or who's got the hack it's like
who
is discipli has disciplined themselves
to create an
a not do list and and really figure out
what is the most important thing for me
to do to build my
business off of social like we're all in
social trying to build our business
but it's the things we do off of social
that really help us
to crush so smart and
uh you know you are obviously on the
context of this we can't go into all the
nuances but
you've helped me understand it's about
building your
business with the right steps in the
right order you're talking all about
email lists and and definitely check out
the show notes think marketing podcasts
for resources from uh
chalene and some powerful things if
that's kind of a new concept to you
um but to your point like you said you
might be on clubhouse
in in a month or in a month and a half
sure because the right things
are out of the way and the right
priorities and again i know we're kind
of highlighting clubhouse it just
happens to be the now thing at the time
of recording but you even text me you
said what do you think about it
and went back when you text me i was
like well i'm not even on it yet
maybe because i'm being an irresponsible
content creator
and entrepreneur or maybe because i'm
focused
and and you are like amen and you know
and i was go we were going back and
forth on that because again i'm like
okay this thing is really good
and i heard this quote that changed my
life once it was that
good is the enemy of the great
that things can be really good that's
that's why it's a distraction going to
the event is good networking is good
but yet what's what really greatness for
your business or greatness for that next
step or reaching that plate of grace
greatness a lot of good things can
eliminate your time down
having you miss out on that maximum
great well i want to get to tip number
five number five
so we can lock in focus kill distraction
and be way more effective this year okay
this one is
you it's going to surprise you i think
people are going to be
weirded out to hear this but i think it
will make sense
dear a business person talk about how
important this is
it's clutter literally clutter
if you are easily distracted which most
people who are listening to this
aren't easily distracted that's a good
thing and a bad thing
what it means for us is that we see
little details that other people miss
those little distractions allow us to
see trends they allow us to spot
the difference that is made up in the
details
but also it creates this
like cloudiness in our brain when
there's a lot of things around it is why
i find the very creative entrepreneurs
they can't work if they can if their
area is cluttered and messy they can't
work if
in the other room they know there's a
big pile of laundry they can't work if
there's just like
messiness all around because their brain
can't just ignore those details
it gets com it gets clouded by those
things
each time you see something that's out
of place your brain actually has to make
a decision you might
think you've just ignored it but you
haven't your brain has said
i see that it doesn't belong there i
don't know why i still have that
and your brain made a decision okay
don't do anything with it right now
but it still made a decision and that
weighs our brains down and it'll
it's harder for us to get into that zone
and to do the things that we need to do
so my fifth tip is this you need to get
rid of
all the freaking clutter you need to
declutter your house you need to
declutter your
most importantly the area the
environment where you work
and i think one of the easiest ways for
you know people to
to do this is to just pick an area that
right now when i say
this area is bringing down your mojo
what area do you think of
like the first thing that came to mind
is it your closet is your workspace
is it the garage like whatever area like
brought you down immediately
just focus on that area and don't think
i'm going to finish it all
uh this weekend just pick one little
corner of it and say okay i've got x
amount of hours like i've got three
hours on saturday
how much of this garage can i tackle in
three hours because you're not gonna be
able to do the whole thing
and just decide and schedule it and know
that that is gonna make you money it's
gonna make you money because it's gonna
give you clarity it's going to help you
to focus
and you can sell that stuff you know it
used to be like
once a year for the last i don't know 10
years i've been doing
a declutter challenge with my audience
and it's been great people are like it's
life-changing i've been able to
i finally had the focus i needed to
start my business or to
focus on my email list or to uh get that
divorce like literally
it holds people back clutter and and
i've always been
you know a big believer in like you just
gotta donate it
last year i decided instead of telling
people
anything that they thought was nice
enough to donate i said let's sell it
let's declutter let's put that all that
stuff in one corner and let's
sell it and i'll teach you how to sell
it so that decluttering isn't just
making you money because you've got more
focus but it's going to make you money
because you can sell that stuff
because the market places on reselling
stuff right now
it's one of the hottest ways for people
to make extra money
that's awesome and what's that called we
call it
learner to earner meaning you know
there's so many of us that we we take
these courses we listen to podcasts we
we we take in all the information but
then we never like apply it and so this
is a challenge where i force people like
okay you're going to learn how to
declutter
and you're going to learn how to list
these things the right way so you can
get maximum dollar with
the least amount of hassle because a lot
of people don't want to do this because
i think it's a hassle
myself included but literally last week
i made three thousand dollars
on pot it's not my business but that's
what i use
anything that i once wore i'm now
selling it on poshmark because that is
the money that i donate to causes that
are important to me like
uh one in six or fighting alzheimer's
like these are
really important organizations and sure
if i donate those clothes i can
you know give a small donation to them
but if i sell those clothes like to be
able to donate three thousand dollars to
a cause
of my choice is really powerful or to
use that money
to invest back into your business to
invest in training to invest in a coach
to invest in
the things are going to take you to the
next level so declutter and then sell
your clutter
that's amazing and so learner-to-earner
that's right i know
uh i saw it last year you're doing it
again of course we'll link it up in the
show notes
and uh if you want to be a part of it
ask yourself think marketing podcast
do you need to declutter if you do
that's probably the challenge
for you and i think a lot of us i know
myself included it's so funny the timing
of this chalene
you know i just turned uh 37 i think
and so we my wife sonia and i have been
married for
15 years and we've been collecting stuff
that's my point
for 15 years we're we're hitting that
you know on our way to 40
and we've been buying you know over the
years you collect stuff you
move yeah stuff shows up in your closet
doesn't quite fit right it's nice you
only wore it once but it doesn't
actually fit right you never wore it
again
tags are still on it um you know
especially
you're like i don't even i don't i never
i haven't used that camera in five years
why do i still have it why am i hanging
on to this little device and that little
device
and these are things that like for you
they have no value but it's
okay this is a wonderful example one of
the gals in our last
uh learner-to-earner challenge had this
like old rotary phone
that her uh mom had given her and she
was like just
felt bad about throwing it away because
she's like you know i just kind of
brought back childhood memories
so she decided to list it on ebay and
sold it within two hours for almost 400
dollars
she's gonna throw it away she wasn't
even gonna donate it because she's like
nobody
is going to need a rotary phone but
so it's just crazy the things that we
think have zero value that somebody else
has been dying
to find it man that's super powerful
so number one is this the best use of my
time ask yourself that question
throughout the day
number two physical reminders so that
you could stay focused number three
schedule your time what gets scheduled
gets done number four
make a do not do list and
crush or embrace the joy of missing out
the jomo and number five declutter
thank you so much for coming on the
podcast
today sean cannell you are the man
thanks for having me
well chalene johnson does it again she
brought you
five ways that you can kill distraction
now chalene has actually been a mentor
of mine for over a decade she brought me
from
being a young mother who was uh in a
depressive state really i had postpartum
depression
i was overweight i was broke and
disgusted in that way
my family and i were in debt we were
just trying to figure out how to make it
online and chalene johnson brought me
from
that woman to this woman today and so i
really recommend that if you know that
your next step is to
grow your online business that you join
the marketing impact academy she did
mention that the doors are open
and they are for a limited time this is
the marketing school
that myself and sean cannell went to to
learn how to do
all the things that helped us grow to
multiple seven figures
online now you know us we teach you
youtube
and we're gonna dive deep into how to do
youtube here on
the podcast as well as in all of our
curriculum that we offer
but shaleen johnson goes really deep
into knowing what your thing is
and then growing that thing sustainably
around the lifestyle that you want to
choose so
if marketing impact academy sounds like
your next step
then definitely go to miabonus.com
because we have some amazing bonuses for
you
for our way of saying thank you for
joining the marketing impact academy we
are giving you
two hours of a mastermind with myself
and sean cannell
with a group of the mia students that
are a part of our community so
if you want to learn how you can get
that to our mastermind valued at over
five thousand dollars
as well as some of our additional
courses that we're throwing in
uh for this offer you can get all of the
details
at miabonus.com you know i would not
recommend something that i have not
taken myself
and i've not seen the results and i can
tell you that from going from the
what should i do all the way into
creating a multiple seven-figure
business
chalene johnson has been my mentor who's
walked me through every single step
of that process and what's so cool is
that when shawn and i met
that was one of those pieces where we're
like oh my goodness you know chalene i
know shalin
and it was a helpful way of us learning
how to drive this vision here at think
media so
if that's your next step miabonus.com
is where you should go now you know that
it is time to
read the review of the day if you are a
part of our think community and you've
not
rated and reviewed this podcast over on
itunes i want to encourage you to do
that
this week now if you're driving right
now obviously do it afterwards but if
you're walking your dog
or doing your dishes or listening to
this while you're working out
i am going to challenge you to grab your
smartphone go to itunes if that's where
you're listening to this podcast on
and rate and review this podcast it
helps us to be able to get this content
out
to more people on the app that are
interested in learning all about how to
grow their youtube channel
and their online business using the
power of youtube and today's review
comes from combat yaomin i hope i said
that right
uh compat yawmin says thanks think team
besides getting great tips and strategy
you help me
keep my why front of mind
with just 36 subscribers and a small
social following
in five videos i've connected with
multiple real families who are getting
value for my personal finance
discussions your podcast keeps me
focused on that
knowing with consistency that uh sorry
knowing knowing with consistent knowing
with consistency this will only grow in
time much
appreciated wow thank you so much and i
love how you said
keeping your why in front of mine
because really
this is challenging growing an online
business growing your youtube channel it
is not for the faint of heart this is a
challenge it's a grind but it is well
worth it when you know your reasons and
you know your whys
and you can stay out of distraction
right using those five tips that chalene
mentioned in this podcast
you're going to be able to reach your
goals and i am so excited for you thank
you for leaving
that review now in the next episode
you're going to want to stay locked and
loaded because we have some more of our
special guests here on the podcast and
then we're going to be jumping into
some really great content this year so
make sure that you are subscribed
wherever you consume the content from
if you're listening to this on youtube i
recommend that you ring that bell so you
get notified
when the podcast goes live and i want to
thank you for being a part of our think
community for
leaning in for taking notes and for
being action takers
if there's one thing that i love so much
about this community it's
the messages that we get on social media
and in email
all about how we have helped you grow
your youtube channel and your online
business and ultimately
been able to go full time those are our
favorite stories so if you have a story
like that
make sure you send us an email or a dm
so that we can
share that with our team and our
community thank you so much for watching
or listening and we'll catch you on the
next episode
[Music]
you